hi everyone sal khan here welcome to the
homeroom live stream uh before we jump
into our a very exciting conversation
with our guest marley diaz i'm
i'll give my standard announcements a
reminder that we are not-for-profit
organizations so if you're in a position
to do so please think about making a
donation at khan academy.org
slash donate we can only exist through
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself i also want to give a shout out
to several organizations that have
stepped up we were already running a
deficit pre-covered covet hits our costs
go up even further uh so special thanks
to bank of america google.org at t
fastly novartis and many of our
supporters large and small
thank you for that help it's what allows
us to keep going and serve tens of
millions of students around the planet
uh but we also do need more help
especially for 2021 so if you're in a
position to do so please think about it
and then my last announcement reminder
that this version of this live stream is
available in podcast form homeroom with
sal the podcast wherever you might find
your podcasts so with that i'm super
excited to introduce our guest marley
diaz she's an author she's the founder
of
1000 black girl books
marley thank you for joining us
thank you for having me
i think you might be our youngest guest
so far so you've already set a record
record i wouldn't be surprised i hear
youngest all the time
okay
you should enjoy it because i used to
hear that and i don't any longer
so so you know there's there's a bunch
of really interesting things that you've
been working on and maybe a good place
to start explain what hashtag one
thousand black girl books is and why you
started it
so a campaign i've launched is called 1
000 black girl books and it has the goal
of collecting and donating books where
black girls are the main characters to
communities across the world
and this originated from me being a
lifelong reader loving to read so much
in fifth grade but my teacher not having
diverse books within our assigned
readings and reading lists so i knew
from my personal experience and loving
to read at home that there were so many
stories that included the experiences of
black girls and people of color and
people with different experiences than
mine but when i went to school i never
had access to the stories that i valued
so much so with 1 000 black girl books
my original goal was to collect 1 000
books where black girls like me were the
main character and now over the past
five years i've collected 13 000 books
where black girls are the main
characters and been able to donate
thousands to not only promote diversity
and inclusion but to also show to other
kids that it is possible to care about
something super deeply at a young age
and to pursue it with the help of your
community and the help of your parents
and i want to double click on that but i
want to remind everyone watching you
know whether you're watching on facebook
or youtube please put questions in our
team is looking at them we will surface
them to marley or myself if applicable
but i want to double click on what you
just said because i think there's a lot
of fifth graders you know 10 year olds
which is when you started who will look
at the world and say i wish the world
was a little bit different i wish i
could change that aspect but they're
like i'm 10 years old what can i do i
mean i know 30 year olds who think that
way i'm 30 years old what can i do much
less if i'm 10 years old
what was it in your mind when you were
10 and said no i think i can make a
difference and
how did you do that how did you put one
foot in front of the other and start
making progress towards this initiative
well i think that's a difficult question
because although i had created something
i wasn't always confident that i would
be able to achieve it so the reason why
i had a thousand is because in my fifth
grade mind not knowing you know like all
the numbers that i can count to i
thought a thousand was the largest
number i could think of so um i felt
like that was a reasonable goal for me
uh like a reasonable yet egregious so i
think for a lot of kids it come it it
really starts with research and
understanding the problem so at first i
thought that only my school and only my
school in west orange new jersey was the
only school that wasn't diverse but as
soon as i complained to my mom she was
explaining to me that her parents had
this issue my dad's great grandparents
have this issue and that it exists in a
larger scheme of things so i think my
first step for kids before they decide
to take action or step out somewhere and
try to protest and fight against
something or to fight for something is
to do more research and to understand
the ways in which this problem exists in
your community and then in the whole
world and kind of a larger grand scheme
of things
and how did that happen so it sounds
like you know your first step you start
talking your parents about it you
learned that this was a broader issue
than just what you're facing in your
school or your area
at age 10 i mean how did you say well
okay what
how did you decide to take action what
was some of what were some of those
first steps that you took one of the
first steps was figuring out what books
do i have in my home that i think every
student should have or what books do i
really care about that i think public
schools need so it was brown throw
dreaming by jacqueline woodson was my
favorite book at the time and my mom had
um and she's still one of my favorites
but i'm not 10 anymore so it's not
necessarily my favorite right now um my
mom would maybe take pictures posing
with the books and what we would do is
she had an office space and we would
post the places you could send the books
and i would say
my daughter marley is a lifelong reader
she really loves to read but she cannot
find books where black girls are the
main characters so after i understood
that oh marley faces this issue but
thousands of people of color across the
nation face this issue as well please
send to hear and hear if you can donate
now people may think that i got an
outpouring of love and support in the
first months but i did not i got some
family friends here some random people
on the internet here and it wasn't
necessarily what i had expected that i
would reach a thousand and become this
large success and and now i've achieved
that over a longer period of time but uh
i think for a lot of kids it's about
using the power of social media asking
your parents to say hey can i talk to my
teachers and ask them if we can put a
drop drop box in our classroom hey can i
talk to my principal and my track coach
and my soccer coach so a lot of the
times it's really reaching out to people
that already exist within your space and
i use social media because i know it was
a helpful tool for people that may live
super far away but it's also important
to reach out to people that we know our
post uh people that are our postmen our
teachers and our community members
and i think there's two
layers at which your initiative is
really interesting one is the direct
layer that you're talking i mean maybe
actually three layers there's the need
to collect you know thousand plus books
for maybe your local community or local
schools i think there's a point in the
signal that it sends to the broader
world that like we should have more
diversity in the books we read
and i actually think the other metapoint
is what we're talking about which is
that you know someone between the ages
of 10 and 15 has a lot of agency in this
world maybe because of social media
maybe because of other things to
actually get people thinking and get
getting people to to take action when
did you realize that this was more than
just a little project where you're you
know saying hey let's get some books
that's kind of a book drive when did you
say hey this is going to really mean
something
and i should put more energy into it
so i started a campaign in november of
2015 and that was me sitting at the
diner with my mom complaining to her
about how much i thought fifth grade
could have been better with better books
um and then after months and months and
my goal was in february i had collected
only about 200 books within the span of
three or so months and i was so
disappointed in myself but towards the
beginning of january and kind of early
february as well there were people in
philadelphia that were reaching out for
me to do radio interviews and to talk
about this um and when people started
mentioning that this was more of a
systemic issue and that the idea of not
having diversity within classrooms
existed for decades before my generation
i thought was when i realized maybe this
can connect to more people than i
imagined because i really only thought
at the beginning that it would be
teachers that understood the problem
that were in classrooms and students but
then understanding that you know
everyone in the united states has to go
to school at some point and now kind of
forcing people to think back on their
experiences and to realize that there
were so many inequities they faced and
now you can help a young person like me
who is now experiencing these inequities
to hopefully stop them and stop them for
future generations of students so when i
heard my grandparents saying that they
experienced this and hearing my parents
say that they experienced this really
opened my eyes to the idea that i could
connect with more people and my story
could matter to a lot more people than i
had imagined
yeah i mean that's an understatement and
you know it's funny because even when
you had you know 200 books in a few
months is not a it's not a small
achievement
i want people to know that i was not
happy with it because a thousand is not
200 but my parents said that even if i
only collected 200 we were still going
to donate them we were still going to
pursue the original goal because the
goal is not necessarily it is a thousand
black robux in the title but the goal is
to learn how to help change the world
the goal is to learn how to give back to
others and for a lot of kids i think
because i've gained so much media
attention they feel as though they have
to set a thousand as their goal or they
have to set a million but in reality
it's about taking your skills taking the
things you love which for me was reading
and then applying them to problems you
face and frustrations you have
no absolutely i can't uh overstate what
you just would you would you just said
you know even the early days of khan
academy i was happy when i was able to
help two or three of my one one cousin
and then two or three cousins but in the
back of my mind says it's gonna be
useful for them could be useful for a
lot of other folks and i think you
you've gone on a very a very very
similar journey you know there's a good
question here from a youtube chloe
o'neil and it you know you're clearly
someone who's a love of b who has a deep
bluff of books you know
how have books affected your life and
i'll extend chloe's question a bit how
have they affected your life and you
know why do you think this is so
important uh to to see yourself or to
see diversity in these stories
well i think reading is super important
for so many reasons
i think one of the main things about why
diversity is important is because so
many kids do not like to read they don't
find it fun and often reading is used as
a punishment within the household
and we're often presented with similar
stories uh hearing that some of the
stories i was assigned my teachers had
read when they were in school which
might seem fun but we also need to think
about how can we change and adapt to the
ways that our classrooms now look the
ways that technology is involved so
reading is super important and having
and supporting so many authors that are
innovating in their writing because you
can connect to the experiences of so
many different types of children uh the
books i was reading mainly had white
boys as the main character and my quote
was kind of that i only read books about
white boys and their dogs
and although that might seem like it's
just an independent experience over 80
of the books published in 2015 the year
when i faced this problem we're about
animals and we're about white people so
i realize now that when we think about
reading we have to make sure that we
show all the aspects of different people
native people's lives black people's
lives white people's lives women girls
children and then make sure that we
include in our classrooms a look out
into the real world and to see our
friends our family strangers that we may
admire our heroes and that all these
people can look different and their
experiences can be different and
difference does not mean a bad thing it
is actually a gift to all of us to
understand and see the perspectives of
new people and ideas
and you know now that you've gone on
this journey and you have these you know
many thousands of books that you've been
able to get i mean i'm assuming you're
you're reading a lot of these books have
there been some stories i mean you
mentioned one is your favorite i mean
what are some of the i i encourage
everyone to go to your website thousand
black girl books but what are some of
your favorites and and why
so some of my favorite personal books
one will always be brown girl dreaming
by jacqueline woodson which was kind of
the accident and the purpose for
starting the campaign because i loved it
so much but some of my favorite picture
books i would say um are probably please
puppy please by spike lee um i would say
president of the fifth grade by sherry
watson um pcb together by renee watson
i've read so many books now at this
point and i i always read the picture
books first because you know they're a
little bit easier for me to read now
that i'm 15.
but when you start to get into those
middle grade books especially for middle
schoolers you realize how important that
time is because your identity starts to
develop your point of view you get more
time to speak you might have more
eloquence and articulus in your ideas
and i always push for that especially
for kids that are within you know fifth
grade to eighth grade to start thinking
about social action as an everyday thing
because now you're starting to recognize
patterns and realize hey people said the
same thing to me in elementary school
and i'm now facing the same problem in
middle school how can i stop this from
happening so i have a resource guide at
the website called
grassrootscommunityfoundation.org
but if you really are a little bit lazy
you can just look up 1000 black girl
books and it'll be there but
it has a list of over a thousand of the
titles that we've collected that are
separated by emerging reader middle
grade reader and independent reader so
if you are in that middle grade that
fifth grade to eighth grade three um
grade three through grade five you can
make sure that you find books that show
these interesting perspectives and can
help you find the words to describe some
of the things you're passionate about
and what you know now that you've i'm
assuming these books you're distributing
in your local area to other places have
what you know have you heard from
students
your age or even younger that said oh
thank you for doing this i never saw
myself what kind of feedback have you
been hearing
it is i am so happy that i'm still able
to hear feedback online especially
through instagram and dms and all these
things but when we got to actually
travel before covet 19 it was so fun
getting to meet kids because i really
really enjoy that experience so much
more i think because people don't have
diversity they don't necessarily
understand that it's an issue so we get
to go to schools in chicago or we get to
go to schools in philadelphia it is so
much fun to see kids be like oh my god
my hair looks just like that oh i wear
glasses just like this oh i have these
beautiful brown eyes and this cover of
the book has a girl with beautiful brown
eyes so it's really amazing um to see
black kids get to see themselves but
it's also really cool to get to see kids
of different races and experiences talk
about why my how much they love those
books and how much they enjoy them
because obviously race is not the only
thing that is super important about
these stories but it matters in our
everyday life and our differences are
something that's worth being celebrated
so it's really awesome to see kids that
are not black girls really understanding
empathizing with and caring about the
experiences of girls that look like me
oh that's that's super super powerful
you know not only are you an avid reader
and a collector i guess you could say a
curator of books yeah
at this point you could say collector i
have so many books now
my personal home as well that i i think
you could say collector
i'm imagining these stacks of thousands
of books all around you which uh
your shelf behind you is more organized
but you got i'm assuming these thousands
of books are art
i have like a whole thing full of books
because whenever i get a signed copy
from like especially self-published
authors or independent authors i keep
all of them in my home in my personal
library because i don't want these
people to think that they don't matter
to me and then all the other books get
donated that we have their copies for so
i keep every at least one copy of almost
every book i try to keep that i really
like and and interested in
you know
i'd love to see that stack sometime uh
you know but you're not only a curator
collector of books but now you're you're
going off and and you're writing now you
know there's another uh question from
youtube taupin airlines i don't know if
they're in airlines or not but they said
what made you want to write a book or
write be a writer
so uh kind of the reason why i wanted to
write marley dice gets done and so can
you was because all the time i get asked
how do you do it how do you do it what
are the steps and it might be nice to
say it to one person you know after i do
an event or i talk to them and i get to
have that independent interaction but i
wanted to put that information out there
and i wrote the book when i was 12 so
it's not necessarily the most updated
version of my methodologies or beliefs
but it really captures the passion and
the interest i have in social action and
reading and it talks a lot about my
family which is something that is super
important to me for people to understand
is really a part of my guiding
principles in life what i believe in
what i care about um and how important
it is that we have caregivers and
educators that invest in children's
curiosity their imagination and their
leadership and because i've had all
those experiences i really wanted to put
it out there and emphasize the
importance of sharing that with kids and
for kids that might feel like it's too
late my parents didn't help me with this
and i don't feel like i can providing
them with solutions and options to work
with their friends their families and
other members of their community to
create social change to feel confident
in their ideas and to hopefully make
some meaningful impacts
so marley this gets it done i mean that
actually sounds like a political slogan
i'll ask you about that in a little bit
but the the uh but it is is that what it
is it's kind of like a handbook of like
hey if you're if you're a young person
or actually not a young person you're
just a person who wants to do stuff in
the world
you know this is this is one way of
tackling it is that is that the goal of
the book to get more people to take
action book is to be a guidebook but
it's also really important to me
and i i think it's kind of an underrated
part of the book is to celebrate um the
gratitude i have for other activists
that have come before me talking about
women like augusta baker who's one of
the she used to be a librarian for the
new york public library and she was so
focused on diversity and inclusion post
harlem renaissance and talking about bob
marley who i'm named after and uh
jamaican revolution like you know
there's there's so many little tidbits i
have and the book is full of color it's
full of pictures and it's inclusive to
people that don't necessarily like to
read and aren't gonna you know pick up a
book that's this heavy with no pictures
uh so it's i made sure to make it a
guidebook for kids obviously but then
for anybody like you said that's
interested in changing the world or
wants to know more about me
it's very cool that you were named after
bob marley
she named me after bob marley so i can i
will never forget my jamaican heritage
and the pride i have in being jamaican
absolutely you know a question here um
from youtube and you know anyone who's
does something in the world especially
something that's public you're bound to
get you have some setbacks some
criticism so this question from youtube
you don youth says did you experience
any negative feedback from people if so
how have you handled it
so i do experience some negative
feedback i think one of the um the
things i hear the most is like why does
it have to be about race uh why does it
like why does it matter and i get that
question i understand it but i think
whenever people ask that they're
insinuating that something about race is
bad or talking about race but it's not
that at all and i think the more that we
make these conversations natural and
don't treat talking about and saying
that i'm proud to be black or saying
that i'm proud to be uh white or from
any other country or any other uh region
it is the problem so what i try to do in
this conversation to not say that i'm a
girl of color or a woman of color but
i'm proud of being a black girl and
that's the way that i'm perceived in the
world and showing pride and who i am is
something that's really important to me
so it can bother me sometimes people say
that because they insinuate that talking
about race is bad but hopefully by
including these conversations with
younger kids they understand that there
is something really cool about being
different from other people and there's
something really cool about trying
different foods learning different
dances understanding different types of
hair and music and culture from new
types of people and new experiences
yeah absolutely i mean exactly your
point isn't that all the books should be
black girl books but you're saying they
should have a reasonable representation
and so i think it's really important
people to know that i'm not trying to
push anybody out i'm not trying to push
any stories out but rather bring new
ones in and provide hopefully a fresh
perspective to diversity and what that
can mean in the classroom
and are there moments where you know i
have to say you you are like 10 times at
least you appear more confident than i
was at your age
i mean are there moments where you feel
like wow um you know i don't know if i'm
gonna be able to pull this off or uh
you're unsure of yourself and how do you
handle that type of thing
yes i feel that more often than people
would imagine and sometimes when i talk
about it people don't believe me but i
definitely do feel weary of my own like
potential and capabilities because i
also think because i've exceeded it and
i'm oftentimes the first person to do
this or the only or the youngest like we
were talking about earlier um i
definitely want to make sure that i i
show well of who i am and i show well of
young people and i want to make sure
that anytime i get an opportunity to be
the first or the youngest or the only
that i am a representative of the
greatness of my generation or people
like me and it's funny that you say that
because i was literally last night
watching your video on summarizing
quantitative data because i had a
statistics quiz today so i get nervous
about stuff like that like any other kid
i had a statistics quiz three hours ago
that i was so nervous for and i watched
your videos to help me so you know i
have those everyday things i feel like
i'm not good enough at something or i'm
not ready for something
no well i'm i'm honored that you that
you were able to leverage khan academy
for that uh but yeah i mean what you're
feeling and i say it too because i think
so many people you look around the world
and it seems like everyone else has
their act together it seems like
everyone else is so confident but i know
for a fact you know i always you know
and i haven't outgrown it hope you'll
probably be on a better track than me
but i'm 44 years old now and i still
have
you know
imposter syndrome i'm in front of you
know giving a presentation to important
people and i'm like how did i end up
here like why am i doing this
am i making any sense at all so i think
it's just important for other people to
realize everyone thinks that um and it's
just a natural part of being being a
human being you know i do want to you
know i i i wasn't joking when i said
that marley diaz gets it done is a nice
political slogan i mean where do you see
your future like what what do you want
to do um you're 15 i mean you got time
but you're already doing a lot it's not
it's not as much times people think but
because i'm 15 but i'm in 11 30.
44.
i'm i'm much better than being 44 but
i'm 15 but i'm in 11th grade so it's
move things are moving a little bit
faster than i thought but i've always
said that i wanted to be interested in
journalism and i've always been
intrigued by telling stories i really
like to write and i find that that's my
most comforting uh hobby but i am better
at math than i give myself credit for so
i'm not really sure at this point but uh
my mom is shaking her head in the
background because she she always any
time i take standardized tests i say i'm
going to do so long english and i always
like out perform a math and never in
english so i know that i have skills
that sometimes are untapped because i
surround myself with books i've always
loved books and now i'm facing where i
have so many things i'm interested in i
have thought about you know politics and
being in public office and helping
people in that way but i want to do
something that makes sure that i'm
always providing a voice to people that
matter to me and to hopefully help my
community in a way that is meaningful
and and not artificial in any way
yeah no i mean i i it is funny when you
say you're 15 and you feel like things
are going by fast i mean i i kind of
felt that when i was 15 and then all of
a sudden i wake up one morning and i'm
44 and i'm like what just happened uh
but anyway hopefully hopefully
it's less jarring hopefully it does not
hurt me because i feel that every day
i'm like this week for me has gone by so
fast and i think like this month will go
by and then the year will go by um but i
i always make sure to look forward to
the future and i keep my options open
because you know it's really cool with
the work i've been able to do i've been
able to meet directors i've been able to
be in front of the camera i've been able
to write articles for uh l.com and work
with glamour and and to see so many
different things that i've always
dreamed of doing um and i hope that in
the future i will be able to help other
kids be uh pursue these interests and to
work with them in collaborating on
creative projects and initiatives
absolutely there's a bunch of questions
continue to come in about your book and
i uh are you hoping to write other books
what other topics are you interested in
i am not so sure about writing other
books i've always been interested in
that but like i told you i like i feel
like one day i'm gonna wake up and i'm
gonna be in college and i i get nervous
about what the future may hold but i am
completely interested in continuing the
work that i do and if that involves
writing a book i think that it would be
really important to do something like
that there are so many other things that
people don't know or i haven't really
talked about when it comes to the ways
that 1000 black girl books has changed
my life and what it's like to be a
teenager that is talking about race in a
new way that is challenging the ideas of
adults and i think that a book that
talks about girls like me um and because
there are more than people know that are
interested in social action would be
something that's really cool
absolutely and you know the time we have
left you know what what messages would
you give to what would you tell the 10
year old version of yourself if you go
back in time or you know 10 year old
kids across the world uh that you know
see something in their community that
they'd like to fix what advice would you
have for them
well i think one thing i always want to
say to people about social action is
that i am not trying to um prove
anything to anybody and i think for a
lot of people they may feel motivated by
the idea that they have been told that
they're not good enough and they are
actively doing something because someone
told them they can't but it's also
really important to always work in the
positive the work i do is because i love
to read and i want to see more books
where black girls are the main
characters i don't start 1000 black girl
books and i didn't start this campaign
because i didn't feel like i mattered
and i had to prove to people that i
matter i showed it because i love to
read and i always want to work in the
positive although i can frame it
negatively i think it's really important
for people that come up with mission
statements or have frustrations to think
about what can i do to make things
better rather than what can i take away
so it's always super important i think
especially for young kids to think more
optimistically and to lead with hope
and to leave the idea that positivity um
and hopefully obviously understanding
the negatives of a situation
understanding that there is systemic
racism in this country and me not having
books is a part of that but also
understanding that what i can do is
hopefully be a small part of this chain
of activists of leaders of powerhouses
of creatives that will hopefully break
apart this horrible system so i think
when i talk about 1 000 black girl books
i always want to talk about it as
something that is great that is amazing
than rather than saying i'm trying to
end something that is horrible that is
disgusting and that is hurting me so i
think for all kids especially use hope
as a motivation for change and to focus
on your frustrations but don't let them
take over your mission statements your
ideas your thoughts and your feelings
about changing the world
well marley i gotta say i think you just
not only inspired a bunch of
ten-year-olds or fifteen-year-olds you
you inspired a bunch of adults because
what you just said about
focusing on positive action i think is a
is a wisdom that you know many people
many multiples of your age uh haven't
fully fully grocked yet uh well thank
you so much this was really uh uh
inspiring and refreshing conversation
and i have no doubt that we're going to
see you much more in the in the years to
come thank you so much
thank you i appreciate it
well thanks everyone for joining uh hope
you enjoyed that conversation as much as
i did with marley uh i i i wasn't
kidding i think we're going to see a lot
of marley in the years ahead in a very
good way in a very positive way uh but
thanks for joining and i look forward to
seeing you at the next uh live stream uh
i think it's going to be next week uh
but i will see you then talk to you
later have a good weekend
you